Here we are, sir!
Hey!
Okay.
Glad you're sitting down, sir.
Because this right here is the finest footwear available on the market today.
Let me introduce you to...
...the future.
Wow, man! This is heavy.
Not heavy at all.
It's actually quite light. Speaking of lights,...
...four hours on a single charge.
I need more density. I mean, my destiny.
Whatever you want.
Shoes! I need shoes!
Well, I got these right here.
Does this power - lace?
Not till 2015.
This is 2015!
It's 2011, sir.
Oh! Great Scott!
The timer surface must've malfunctioned.
I don't know what that means, sir.
Where's he going?
Whoa! He made like a tree and got outta here.
There's a fire in the parking lot, guys!
Anybody wanna put out the fire in the parking lot?
Kevin, you wanna go down there?